it's the british navy's biggest
and most powerful warship the hms queen
elizabeth
aircraft carrier is leading a flotilla
of navy ships
on its maiden deployment it's the
largest
concentration of british air and
maritime power in years
prime minister boris johnson says the
deployment will help to strengthen
british soft power such as belief in
democracy
and the rule of law analysts say
geopolitics is at play it's also doing
it because there are tensions over
taiwan
and britain like the eu and other major
powers
have an interest in not seeing that
become an armed conflict
and so they have to demonstrate that
their country is willing to stand up
against the use of force against it and
i also feel
it's it's an early signal to the biden
administration that britain
is a player an ally no longer trapped in
europe but able to act
independently the flotilla is expected
to sail through the south china sea
a large part of which china has laid
claim to
part of its mission is to demonstrate
freedom of navigation
in the south china sea but the chinese
government
sees this as a provocation in recent
years
it has increased its military spending
and grown more assertive in its claims
over the south china sea
tensions are already heightened since
2015 uh when china began
island building activities in the south
china sea but what i'm worried now is
that with the collection of
so many military assets in this region
there's going to be
the higher chance of miscalculation the
uk
recently announced it will permanently
deploy two warships in
asian waters after the flotilla sails to
japan
in september the deployment is part of
the british government's tilt towards
the indo-pacific
much like the u.s pivot to asia under
former u.s president barack obama
it is in part a response to china's
growing influence
and that makes the south china sea more
of a potential flash point
florence louis al jazeera kuala lumpur